[Music]
what up guys goes on an animatic here
for anime uproar and we got two big
pieces of news tree today so the first
big piece of news is that we're
organizing a contest where you get to
create your own my hero academia
character all you have to do is submit
your idea for a hero name a quirk and a
backstory no more than 200 words and the
winning design will be drawn and brought
to life by professional artist who's oh
man coos Oh Marie actually makes his
living drawing manga sweet is truly a
pro artist and he's already done some
work for us in the past he did this
awesome drawing of our mascot and he's
also already drawn some awesome my hero
academia characters like check out this
bakugan if you want to enter the contest
that have your design brought to life by
a professional artist if it wins all you
have to do is reply on the thread on our
Twitter and Instagram at anime roar
links are in the description and if you
prefer to use discord you can check out
our anime upper discord link in the
description and we have some people
there who volunteer to take your
submission big thank you to laws and sin
for volunteering to do that you can find
them by checking the pin message in our
main discord shop the winners will be
picked by myself
knocks Taku and breaks from all-day
anime on this week's ran cafe which
takes place on Thursday at 5 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time and of course if
you don't know ran cafe is an anime
podcast that we host live every week
either on this channel animal roar or on
NOK stock whose channel 5 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time every Thursday and the
second piece of news is that we could be
at con Bravo this weekend from July 27
to July 29th the con will take place in
Hamilton Ontario Canada and we'll be
there Saturday and Sunday you can see
the schedule on screen and also in the
description we're gonna be doing
youtuber QA and autographs we're also
gonna be on different panels including
the let's talk anime panel and hosting
the anime and philosophy panel so that
should be really fun so yeah that's
gonna be a lot of fun we're hopefully
gonna meet some more favorite youtubers
there including like soup
eyepatch wolf glass reflection that
should be pretty crazy and don't forget
to enter the contest by this Thursday
then in rank of a we're gonna be
debating the top 16 is gonna be a
tournament art style debate is gonna be
a lot of fun so ya guys hope to see you
at the con make sure to enter the
contest and until next time see ya space
cowboys
[Music]
you